foreign
that most people don't want to think
about
it's too frightening and it doesn't seem
real that threat is Civil War
since 1946
over 250 Civil Wars have broken out and
that number continues to increase there
are now almost 50 percent more Civil
Wars than there were in 2001.
I've been studying Civil Wars for over
30 years I've interviewed members of
Famas in the West Bank ex shouldn't find
members in Northern Ireland former
members of the farc in Columbia I've
stood on top of the Golan Heights at and
stared into Syria at the top of the
Syrian Civil War I've driven across
Zimbabwe as the military was planning
its coup against Robert Mugabe I've been
followed and interrogated by members of
myanmar's Hunter
in 2017 I was asked to serve on a task
force run by the CIA called the
political instability Task Force One of
the goals of that task force was to come
up with a model to help the U.S
government predict what countries around
the world were likely to experience
ethnic conflict and Civil War it turns
out that predicting Civil War is
possible solid data exists on where and
when these conflicts are likely to break
out it's just that most people don't
know that
the task force was comprised of two
types of people experts on Civil War
like myself and data analysts
the experts came up with 38 different
factors that they thought could
potentially lead a country towards Civil
War and some of those factors seemed
obvious like whether a country was poor
had lots of income inequality or had a
government that heavily discriminated
against one particular group
it turns out that only two factors were
highly predictive and they weren't the
ones the experts expected
the first was whether a country was an
anocracy anocracy is just a fancy term
for partial democracy it's a government
that's neither fully Democratic nor
fully autocratic it's something in
between so think about Hungary today
Hungary holds elections hungarians
eagerly go out and vote it's just that
whoever wins those elections can
basically do whatever they want
the second Factor was whether citizens
in these inocracies had formed political
parties around identity rather than
ideology
so rather than joining a party because
you were liberal or conservative
capitalist or communist you joined a
party because you were black or white
Christian or Muslim Serb or croat
if a country had these two features the
task force considered it at high risk of
political violence and put it on a watch
list was actually called the watch list
and it was sent to the White House
so here I was sitting in a hotel
conference room in Suburban Virginia
four times a year with a room full of
really smart people and we talked about
countries in Africa the Middle East
Central Asia but we never ever talked
about the United States
that's because the CIA is legally not
allowed to monitor the United States or
its citizens and that's exactly the way
it should be
but I was a private citizen and I had
this information and I could see that
both of these factors were emerging in
my own country and they were emerging at
a surprisingly fast rate
the US's democracy has been downgraded
three times since 2016.
2016 it was downgraded because
International election monitors had
considered the 2016 election free but
not entirely Fair
America's own intelligence agencies had
found that the Russians had in fact
meddled in that election
it was downgraded again in 2019 when the
White House refused to comply with
requests by Congress for information
and it was downgraded a final time at
the end of 2020 when President Trump
refused to accept his loss the 2020
election and actively attempted to
overturn the results
between December of 2020 and early 2021
the United States was officially
classified as an inocracy
if the task force had been allowed to
Monitor and study the United States it
likely would have considered it at high
risk of political instability and
political violence in December of 2020
just a few weeks before the January 6
Insurrection and it likely would have
put the United States on the watch list
we also know who tends to start civil
wars and again it's not the people most
of us think
it is not the poorest people in society
it is not the people who are most
oppressed by their government
the people who tend to start civil wars
especially ethnically based Civil Wars
are the groups that had once been
politically dominant but are in Decline
if you think back to the former
Yugoslavia
serbs had enjoyed most of the positions
in government and the military
throughout the Cold War for decades for
decades
but they were the ones who stood the to
lose the most as Yugoslavia democratized
the serbs started that war
Iraq sunnis similarly enjoyed most of
the key positions in the military and in
government under Saddam Hussein but when
the United States toppled Saddam Hussein
they also threw the sunnis out of their
positions it was the sunnis who started
that war
in the United States the rise of
militias
has been driven primarily by white men
who see America's identity changing in
ways that directly threatens their
status
they were the ones who marched on the
capitol on January 6.
so why is this happening now
it's happening now because of
demographic change
the United States is in the midst of a
major transition from a country whose
population is majority White
to a country whose population will be
majority non-white
the United States will be the first
country to go through this but others
are going to follow Canada is likely to
be next followed by New Zealand and then
the UK and eventually all the
English-speaking countries of the world
this is likely to be especially true if
climate change causes citizens from the
global South to increasingly move north
these countries are going to be looking
to the United States to see how we
manage this demographic shift
Americans can allow this transition to
tear us apart
or we could use it to come together to
show the world how to manage this change
and in the process create a truly
multi-ethnic multi-religious democracy
so how do you do this
the first thing we have to do is address
the two big risk factors of Civil War
anocracy and identity politics
to address inocracy we have to improve
the rule of law we have to ensure equal
access to every citizen to the vote we
have to reduce corruption and we have to
improve the quality of government
services
but reforming a government takes time
those are not easy things to do and it
often seems impossible that's exactly
where the United States is today almost
paralyzed
this is where business can come in
30 years ago most of us thought that
South Africa was barreling towards Civil
War
black South Africans were increasingly
protesting the brutality of the white
apartheid regime and the government
responded with more brutality
but then something happened
the business Community stepped in and
demanded real democracy
they did this because they had been
suffering under years of crushing
economic sanctions and eventually they
had to choose between apartheid and
Prophets and they chose profits
and when they went to the government and
said we will no longer support you the
apartheid regime knew it could not
survive and reform happened quickly
the business Community can also help
address identity politics by investing
in those communities that have been left
behind by globalization and by free
trade agreements like NAFTA in the
United States it was the working class
that disproportionately suffered
those are the communities that are the
most angry and the most resentful today
businesses can invest in Better Health
Care better education and a higher
minimum wage
so that they create a group of people
who are hopeful about the future
and less vulnerable to the calls by
extremists to burn the system down
but there's perhaps an easier solution
at least in the short term
it's in the short term
and that is to regulate social media
especially the algorithms that push out
the most incendiary and divisive
material
I'm not saying that we should censor
Free Speech let people put whatever they
want on social media
but do not allow the algorithms to
amplify the messages by bullies and hate
mongers and conspiracy theorists and
enemies of democracy if we take away
their bullhorn their influence will
decline
I've interviewed a lot of people who
have lived through a Civil War and they
all say the same thing
I didn't see it coming I didn't see it
coming
Brina Kovac was a young mother living in
Sarajevo at the beginning of the Bosnian
Civil War
she told me that in the months and weeks
leading up to that war life seemed
normal she went to work
she took weekend holidays with her
husband she they went to the weddings of
their friends
but then one night in March of 1992 when
she was at home with her newborn son
the light suddenly went out
and then she said you started to hear
machine guns
it doesn't have to be this way
we know an enormous amount about why
these terrible Wars start
we know that the people intent on
violence have a Playbook we know what
that Playbook is
but there's no reason why we the
Democracy loving people of this world
can't create our own Playbook to prevent
Civil War
but to do that we have to be brave
enough to fight for real democracy
strong democracy because only by
fighting for democracy can we ensure
that we will truly get peace thank you
foreign